Voilà je voulais faire la liste des expressions ou des trucs que les gens font quand ils parlent qui m'énervent.
LES PIRES EXPRESSONS
Par exemple, dans la vie, des fois y'a des mecs quand tu les fait rire, ils t'insultent
(rire) T'es con
Attends, moi quand on me fait rire  je fais pas :
(rire) fils de p***,  j'te bai*e !!
Après, il y a la phrase fantôme
Je veux dire, c'est des mecs qui disent des mots mais au final ils ont toujours rien dit
ouais non mais voilà après bon d'accord mais personnellement c'est vrai que bon ouais voilà mais clairement ouais
0 IDEES EXPRIMES
Après des fois y'a des mecs quand on leurs pose une question, ils répondent oui et non
je ne sais pas, par exemple, quand on leur demande si ils ont aimé le film : alors oui et non
Les gars faut choisir dans la vie soit tu dis oui soit tu dis non, imagine que tu couche avec une fille :
La capote a éclaté j'espere que tu n'as pas le sida
Euhhhhhhhhhh alors oui et non
Après j'aime pas les gens qui après avoir vu un film, sortent cette expression : "ouais j'ai trouvé ça pas mal, mais la fin était un peu longué"
y a que quand on voit un film qu'on dit "un peu longué"
Jamais un criminel va dire: j'ai fait 15 ans de thôle j'te cache pas que j'ai trouvé ça un peu longué
Après y'a un truc c'est le ouais aspiré
y'a des mec, quand tu leurs parlent et qu'ils t'écoutent, ils disent le mot ouais en aspirant de l'air
ouais, ouais(aspiré), ouais, ouais(aspiré)
Premièrement ça te donne un petit coté secrétaire ou madame pipi, très dégueulasse
ouais(aspiré)
Deuxièmement c'est bizarre parce que c'est le seul mot qu'on peut dire en aspirant, jamais personne va faire :
-Salut(aspiré) ça va(aspiré)
-Ouais et toi ?
-Ouais(aspiré), ça va(aspiré)
Y'a une expression aussi qui m'énerve, c'est une expression qui consiste a demander si c'est une blague
Oh m*rde , j'suis parti de chez moi, j'ai complètement oublié de te ramener ton album de One Directions
C'est une blague ?
Evidemment que c'est pas une blague, comme si on allait répondre :
Ouais ouais carrément c'est une blague d'ailleurs c'est la vanne d'intro de mon prochain One Man Show
"j'ai oublié ton CD à la maison", je pense qu'ils vont vraiment rigoler, c'est très très bien trouvé
Bon après évidemment y'a aussi les mecs un peu à l'ancienne qui au lieu d'utiliser leurs propres mots
préfèrent utiliser des phrases pré-conçues, un peu ringardes
t'façon comme j'dis toujours, qui peut le moins peut le plus
Ah, va savoir...
Allez, qu'a cela ne tienne
Ma foi, c'est la vie
t'façon comme on dit, bien manger c'est le début du bonheur, ah nan ça c'est une pub
non non je me suis trompé
Dans le même genre,  y'a aussi les mecs qui font un commentaire dès que t'éternues
(éternuement)
Ah, à tes souhaits
Ah, à tes amours
(éternuement)
-Ah, à tes a...
-BON, j'ai la grippe tu vas pas le dire toute la journée à chaque fois
Après y'a les bilingues en anglais qui, juste pour se la péter,aiment bien caser des petites expressions,
En faisant genre ils ont pas fait exprès
Nan mais cette histoire elle m'a clairement pris la tête, enfin bon, anyway, euhhhhhhhhhh
Bizarrement y'a que les bilingues en anglais qui font ça
J'veux dire y'a jamais un mec qui fait :
Nan mais cette histoire elle m'a pris la tête, fin bon, kein problem, et donc j'disait euhh
enfin je finirait par 4 expressions qui me donnent envie de donner des sortes de claques virtuelles au mec qui les emploient
Il s'agit des mecs qui disent :
Bon pour le week-end prochain, je sait pas, disons qu'on met une option là dessus (bruit de claque)
Waouh, c'est tellement so 2012 (bruit de claque)
-Moi je trouve qu'il me vas assez bien ce t-shirt
-Ou pas (bruit de claque)
Eh, mardi prochain c'est ma fête, et c'est aussi le jour de la sortie du nouvel album des Daft punk
Coïncidence ? Je ne pense pas ! (bruit de claque) ça fait mat p*tain
J'ai vu que vous étiez plus d'1,5 millions à avoir cliqué ici pour vous abonner à ma chaine Youtube
Ça me fait trop trop plaisir donc merci à toutes et à tous pour ça
Quand je me suis réveillé ce matin et que j'ai vu ça, j'ai fait :  Waouh, C'est une blague ?
(musique de fin)